[Musique]
en
ans
[Musique]
sauf pour les cantines de coupe et
participe à la purification de cette
heure-là participe à l'équilibré de
l'écosystème par ceux ci à nous donner
un environnement sain et aujourd'hui
nous en tant que personne humaine on
associe la de vivre dans un
environnement sain certes le besoin de
surfaces où habitait et la star n'en
disconvient pas mais c'est pas tout
autant que ipso facto il faut aller vers
la qualité après l'afrique et éradiquer
la mer noire
[Musique]
un grand problème écologique est en
train de se mettre en place et ça risque
d'être fatale dans les années à venir
aujourd'hui nous sommes aussi en train
de dire à la mer il faut rentrer dans la
terre et ce à l'elysée les sols est ce
qui va se passer c'est que les bâtiments
qui sont en arrière sur des kilomètres
vont être rangés au niveau des
fondations par cette eau salée qui va
donc éroder le faire et donc peu
fragilisé les bâtiments ce qui peut être
un risque vraiment catastrophique pour
pour les êtres humains
[Musique]
nous voulons donner un exemple à toutes
les associations de jeunes qui sont ici
au sénégal que effectivement avec des
actions communautaires avec l'engagement
des jeunes ont bel et bien le boisé tout
le littoral
parce que le littoral c'est pour moi un
bien commun tout le monde doit doit y
avoir accès et pour cela également
tout le monde m'a également donné du
sien pour sa préservation
[Musique]
il nous apparaît en train d en dresser
et on s'est dit mais pourquoi pas écrire
une chance mais ne pas écrire une
chanson sous forme de deux
revendications mais écrire donner une
dimension poétique à la chanson c'est à
dire nous rappeler de ce qui se passait
ici on perd le nord